>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Beacher Wiggins:
I'm Beacher Wiggins,
director for acquisitions
and bibliographic access.
And we want to welcome you
to another in the series
of library services LCs digital
future and you that has been
and continues to be coordinated
by Angela Kinney
and Judith Cannon.
And this particular one they
had to expend extra energy
because I confused them with
my timing and my availability.
So I express extra thanks
for today's session.
Today we want to update you
on where we are with BIBFRAME.
We won't have formal
introductions, we'll have each
of us introduce ourselves as
we speak and there will be four
of us by the end of the session.
I will be the briefest of all,
you will be pleased to hear.
[ Phone Ringing ]
[ Laughter ]
Excuse me.
Is this being recorded?
BIBFRAME has been underway
now, the BIBFRAME pilot
and pilot 2 has been underway
now for almost a year.
And we've been, the staff who've
been involved have been using
the BIBFRAME 2.0 model.
We launched this pilot to
test the library's approach
to linked open data using
the RDF resource description
format structure.
We are at a point now where we
are assessing the pilot based
on the work of the 60
or so staff members
who have been participating
in this
for the past 11 or so months.
These staff have been
cataloguing their materials
that they received on a regular
basis daily using BIBFRAME.
And in most instances,
they are also continuing
to catalog those materials
using the MARC format.
So there's been a lot of
contribution on the part
of participants who
have taken part in this.
Before we depart next week
for the American Library
Association annual conference
in New Orleans we
will issue a report
of what we've learned during
the pilot based on the input,
the feedback and the
output of the participants.
Staff in the network development
and MARC standards
office net dev
and in COIN are frantically
now putting together the final
touches on the report
for my review.
Based on our report and
assessment we also want
to be able to make some
definitive statements
about LC's commitment
to BIBFRAME.
Today Nate Trail, Jodi
Williamschen, Les Hawkins
and I will give you our LC
colleagues an update before we
do similar briefings and updates
for our external
colleagues in New Orleans.
I'll speak briefly about
the goals of the pilot.
These goals form the framework
of the pilot assessment
and the report that
will be issued shortly
that you'll all be seeing.
Nate will address the
BIBFRAME database,
the conversion process,
and related points.
Les and Jodi will focus
on the BIBFRAME editor
and the changes made
to it for the pilot.
And improvements that were
made during the pilot based
on the feedback from the
participants engaged in it.
The goals were set from
three perspectives,
mine as the director, net
dev's as the technical lead
in the project, and COIN
as the training lead.
From my perspective as director
I want us to be to determine
that BIBFRAME can be applied
to a large participant pool,
i.e. that BIBFRAME will be
scalable and could be adopted
by institutions of any size.
If the Library of Congress can
do it anyone should be able to.
I want to determine that LC
will indeed pursue BIBFRAME
as the data pathway and
the ultimate replacement
for the MARC format.
And lastly, I want to be
able to announce the decision
to the library and
the vendor community
because until the
library is able
to make a firm commitment
we won't get the buy-in
and the system development
that will be needed
to make BIBFRAME a
viable library community
format structure.
To reach such a decision
point much work was required
in the technical arena and the
associated training sphere.
From the net dev perspective
what was desired was a realistic
cataloging environment
that allow catalogers
to create bibliographic resource
and authority descriptions
in BIBFRAME just as
they are able to do
in the MARC environment.
To achieve this the database
conversion was required,
a database conversion was
required, i.e. MARC to BIBFRAME.
And you'll hear a bit
more about that from Nate.
There are many steps involved
in making this a reality.
The pilot assessment that I
talked about will cover this
and show how readily
we were able
to address the various issues
and concerns that were raised.
Associated with the
converted database was a need
for an input tool,
the BIBFRAME editor
that will enable catalogers to
handily and easily input data
for the BIBFRAME descriptions
that they were creating.
Much of the editor improvements
reflected the COIN perspective
that is from both the teaching
perspective and vantage point,
as well as the ongoing
interaction
with the pilot participants
and the improvements
that were made along
the way to the editor.
For pilot 2 a lot of
energy and effort went
into enhancing the editor
and we hope we'll have a
better tool as we move forward.
And Les and Jodi will talk
more about that shortly.
So now I ask you to stay tuned
for the report and assessment
that will come out by next week.
And now we will hear Nate talk
about the database and some
of the work associated
with that.
>> Nate Trail: Good morning
everyone, I'm glad to see
that some of us are not
[inaudible] or are we more nerdy
than we care to admit.
So yeah, I'm going to talk
about the BIBFRAME database
and conversions between MARC and
BIBFRAME, and some other things.
So this is an overview of the
data flow from MARC to BIBFRAME.
First of all, we take
all of our name title
and title authority records out
of ID and we do a conversion
from MARC authorities
to BIBFRAME,
convert those to works.
And then we convert all the
MARC records and try to match
against those name title
authority works and store them
in the database as well.
And then the BIBFRAME
description circle represents
where the editor is that you
can natively create a brand-new
BIBFRAME description or
call something up out
of the database, edit
it and save it back.
And during all that time
there are links between
and among the BIBFRAME
database itself and IDloc.gov.
So there's about 1.2 million
title and name title authorities
that we converted to BIB,
about 17 million BIB records,
and that includes some stuff
that we don't distribute
outside.
But we wanted to try to
create a catalog just
like the Voyager catalog
system has so that
when somebody is doing
descriptions they can call
up whatever is available
inside the catalog.
We have daily feeds coming
from both ID and the ILS.
And since people are doing
duplicate entry we have
to be able to block things
where the cataloger created
it natively in BIBFRAME,
and we don't want the record
from the ILS to come
back through.
So we're doing a merging
that takes a converted record
and matches it to
existing BIB records.
And we have also processes
that allow us to validate
between when a BIBFRAME
description is natively created
and converted to RDF,
and converted to JSON
or converted back to XML we
want to be able to validate
that that is still
a good structure.
So there's a lot of different
processes and workflows
that we have to maintain
and support,
and places where things can
break all the way through.
So this is a picture of
our cataloging homepage,
it's not the BIBFRAME
database homepage.
It's not particularly meant for
outside users but it can be.
We're focusing on allowing the
cataloger to do their work,
and we're also focusing on
being able to count things for.
When Beecher [assumed
spelling] wants to know how many
of one thing or how
many of another.
So we want to be able to support
the workflows, but we also want
to do statistical analysis on
you know what did we get right,
what did we get wrong,
how can we clean
up a certain batch of records.
So there's all kinds
of different ways
of cutting the data once
it's in the BIBFRAME.
Okay so there's keyword
searching,
there's title searching,
name and subject searching.
There are facets once you get
in by language and LC class.
There are all kinds of
filtering by work or instance.
There's is left anchor browsing.
We'll do some of those.
So this is a title search for
Babes in Toyland and you can see
that when you look down the
left these refinements are
different facets.
So for Babes in Toyland there's
a whole bunch of notated music,
some movies, some
audio, etcetera.
And let's see for left anchor
browsing we can try an imprint.
So these are all the imprints
of Harcourt [assumed spelling]
and you can see that on
the title page of many
of these things it's expressed
in a bunch of different ways.
They're probably all the
same publisher but right now
from the MARC record
this is what we have.
So as we go through these
processes we're probably going
to go behind the scenes
and say let's see how many
of these things we can
say are the same publisher
or from the same
publishing agency
and link them together better.
But at least this way
we have them in a line
and you can do quick
analysis of these things.
So the editor is tied tightly
to the database and it allows us
to take up any description
for editing as long as it's
within a particular
defined profile.
And the reason for profiles is
that BIBFRAME is a very large
descriptive container set,
but say notated music has a
pretty defined set of things
that you want to
use to describe.
So the profile allows
us to narrow
down what we want the
cataloger to be able to do
and be required to do.
So you can call up the record
and edit its description
or you can add an
instance or an item.
You can decide that
this particular thing
that you're working on is linked
to another description
in the database.
And you can link it to
name authority records
so that we're not just entering
strings anymore we're actually
linking to a defined
name authority
or subject LSH authority,
etcetera.
And then you can store
it back in the database
and it looks just like
all the other descriptions
that we already have.
But there are a number of issues
that we've discovered
as we go along.
We don't have a profile
for every type
of description that there is.
And when we do a
conversion of a record
from MARC there isn't really
an exact one-to-one match
that tells us that this
previously MARC record should
belong to this BIBFRAME profile.
So when you call up a record
we have to make a decision
of which profile we're
going to put it into.
And when you do that you make
that default decision there
are RDF description elements
that are not available
to be edited then
in that BIBFRAME profile.
So what do we do with
that information?
So far, we have said we're going
to keep it and post it back
but we're not going to allow you
to edit it which is a problem
for people who want to be able
to actually edit
the whole thing.
So the editor itself has got
some things that we need to work
through but we're
discovering these things.
There's a difference
between an IBC update
and a clone even though it looks
like you're doing
the same thing.
So if you see an initial
bibliographic control record
in the database and you want
to call it up and edit it
and save it back
you're basically trying
to save the same set
of descriptions back,
a work instance and item.
But if you want to clone
something you want to call
up that same record but save it
under a different identifier.
So we've had to find ways
to say clone this thing,
give it a new identifier,
probably the LCCN
and then save it back
completely parallel
but having basically the same
metadata except for a new title
or something like that.
And catalogers keep coming up
with new ways of showing us
that we haven't gotten
it done yet,
so we keep doing new profiles.
So between the database and
the editor then when you call
up a description we have to
do a little bit of wrangling
because we store the data in XML
but the editor wants
to see JSON.
So our RDF has got
to be expressible in
a variety of ways.
So in the database on any
given record you'll see
that you can convert it to
all those different things.
And I talked little bit
about the profiles being one
of the mechanisms that are
causing us problems even though
they let us have a lot
of advantages as well.
There is also a distinction
between how something is
created natively in BIBFRAME
versus how it was
converted from a MARC record.
So you can, if you are doing
a mass conversion you make
decisions about what happens
to the [inaudible], etcetera.
But when somebody is
natively creating it
in BIBFRAME you can actually
know their intent a lot better.
So BIBFRAME native descriptions
are in some ways better
but they need to be equivalent
so that they live
side-by-side in the database.
So there's about
five different ways
that you can express
a source based
on whether it was
created natively or not.
But we have to find ways to make
it all look the same so that
when you push a button to
query it it's queriable
[phonetic] identically.
So when we do the merging what
we're doing is we're trying
to match basically on
the name and the title.
If we find a match
when something is
converted we'll take the work
and instance that's created,
we'll take the subjects
and the classification data
and put it onto the work
that we found in the database.
And we'll discard
the work and attach
that instance to that work.
So this has been
good in some ways
but it's also been problematic
because some of the times
when you have a name title
that matches you really want
to do an RDA expression work
instead of doing a merge
and saying this is an instance
of that other work
in the database.
So we're going to have to
go back through the database
and look for places where the
thing should not be a merge
onto another instance --
onto another work but
should actually be a work
that has an expression-like
relationship to the work
that was found in the database.
So also, on bibliographic
records there's 7XX related
titles and those we
need to be able to --
oh no I'm sorry, 7XX names.
So somebody who's an illustrator
of a work when we do a merge
and we drop the work
the illustrator
of something also goes away.
Because the original work
does not have an illustrator
but this particular
edition does.
So the merge in that case
saying that this is an instance
of that may be true but we've
lost some key information
about that.
And the illustrator
should not be merged
onto the original work.
So we really need to
have a work in between
that says this is a work in its
own right with an illustrator
but it's linked to
that original work.
And sometimes of course there
are no title or untitled things
so we don't want to merge those.
So the merge specs it's
pretty detailed here,
I'll just let you read it
it's not that interesting.
Here's an instance where
something worked quite well.
And earlier today that image
wasn't working so I'm glad
to see the cover art
thing got put back in.
So this BIB ID 203786 was merged
with this name authority
work Huckleberry Finn.
And when you look at that
Huckleberry Finn you can see
that it's related to a
whole bunch of other stuff.
So in BIBFRAME we say
that something is related
to something else and then using
the sparkle query language were
able to say that a particular
work has a relationship
to something else.
But then you can also
say what else is related
to that other thing, and you
can bring things together
in much more interesting ways.
Okay so this is an
instance where it worked
but you know probably the
-- no, that didn't work.
Let's go back to it.
Sorry. Try again.
So Concerto selections is
probably not an actual work it's
just a colocation mechanism
but it did bring these
things altogether.
I would say that all of these
instances probably have,
should be works in their own
right and be somehow related
to this overall collection work.
So in a future pass we'll
straighten that out.
All right, so when we do
this conversion we've noticed
that the name titles that
were described in ID have lots
of extra information like
the media and the form,
etcetera that are disambiguated
from previous works.
And so what we're going
to do now is we're going
to take a work that has some
of these extra subheadings,
chop off that subheading and
say all right can I find a name
title match with everything
except for this little part.
And if I do make
that match I'm going
to make a relationship
between those things.
And all of these things
that I've highlighted
in red are candidates
for such linking.
Bibliographic records have the
same thing, when they have a 130
with lots of subparts we should
be able to chop off the subparts
and say there is
some relationship
between everything
except for that last node,
and so we're trying
to do that as well.
And here's what I was talking
about 7XX related titles.
Those things we should be
able to say formulate the name
and title and see if you can
find a match in the database,
and make a direct link
between those things.
So here's one where it actually
did work, a vocal score.
So this is a Rossini vocal score
and the related work does
not have vocal score on it.
Okay here's a translation,
Ultimate Ironman.
So this one is in
Greek and it linked
to the name title authority work
which has no language on it.
But then it turns out that
because we're asking questions
of it there's also a
Croatian translation.
And I haven't yet done it
but the Croatian translation
really should be a sibling
of the first one that I
started with so that on
that old work you
should be able to say
and what other languages
has this been translated
into without having to go
up to the higher level.
So there are lots of things
down the right-hand side
that we've just started
exploiting the nature of RDF
in creating these links.
Okay 130K selections.
So these poems are
related to each other
and apparently translated
into Romanian as well.
But here are some
of the actual poems
and not just the
overall selection work.
Okay and the bibliographic
record with 7XX-related titles.
I've only been doing this
on an experimental basis
so the whole database has
not been completely converted
to having all these links.
But this poem I guess
or song is related
to a lot of other things.
[ Laughter ]
okay so still to come, I
started this presentation,
I gave it in California in April
and I had a slide called still
to come, and it had
all these things on it.
And I realized when I opened it
up that we've already gotten
started on most of these things,
so I crossed them off here.
We have exported all the
RDF works and instances
and stored them at ID for
people who are interested
in the big libraries to be
able to download and ingest
into their own databases
and do something with.
We are linking related
titles MARC 7XX.
The name title authority
records on a daily basis,
those things are
linking to each other.
We haven't gone back and
done the whole thing yet.
And we're starting to experiment
with linking instead of merging
on things that should
be RDA expression works.
So we're still looking for more
ways to link and we're thinking
about ingesting different
types of data including zip
and Onyx records, although some
of those are already
in the database.
So getting the data upstream
a little bit may not be
that useful but we'll see.
Casellini, the Italian
cataloging partner that we have,
has a conversion of their
own and they've converted all
of our database and
gave it back to us.
And they can give us
weekly conversions
of different records
if we want it.
So we're doing an
experiment with how do we look
at that data, convert it
to whatever it needs to be
for us, and ingest it.
And that's all I
have, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jodi Williamschen: So
I'm Jodi Williamschen,
I joined the library a
year ago from Oakland,
California where I worked
for Innovative Interfaces.
I'm very happy for the
Capitals, I'm way happier
for the Golden State Warriors.
And Les and I are going to talk
about using the BIBFRAME editor.
So I'll start out with
just a quick overview
of selected portions
of the editor starting
with there's the URI
or URL if you wanted
to go explore it yourself.
And we've set up a lot of
editor profiles that are based
on the materials
cataloged in the library,
as Nate said we haven't covered
everything yet but we're trying.
One of the ones that we added
during the pilot is the rare
materials profile, and it
has some special elements
that the rare materials
cataloger who's
in the pilot requested.
This is how the editor profile
for a monograph work looks,
there's just a lot of
fields that can be filled.
And a lot of them
underneath that are tied
to controlled vocabularies so
there's a lot of type-aheads
and lookups so that you
don't have to remember
to type everything
in from scratch.
This is an example of
one of the type-aheads.
So for form genre it's
tied to the Library
of Congress genre form thesaurus
so you can just start typing.
And then you can select the term
that you want, highlight it,
and it goes into the editor.
And behind the scenes
the URI that's associated
with that term that's in
id.loc.gov is assigned
to the field, and then
you get a nice true triple
on the backend with URIs.
And also, I've been
experimenting
with different ways to
put subject headings
in where you can
search each component
of a complex subject
heading separately
and get a URI for
each component.
And they are all stored
together in the output.
Where possible we've tried to
put a lot of standard values in.
So the language lookup is
searching the MARC code list
for languages.
And we've added in
other specialized terms
that are part of
the RDA registry.
We've put them into ID just
to keep all the terminology
in-house
but I imagine some day we
would be directly linking
out to the RDA registry
for these types
of terms and probably more.
In each profile we've also tried
to customize standard
values where possible.
So there's a lot of the formats
have a media type of unmediated
and a carrier type of volume.
But then we also have video and
video disk for the DVD profile.
Audio and audio disk for
all of the CD profiles.
And projected and [inaudible]
for the 35-millimeter profile.
And we've also customized
what fields are included
in each profile.
So these are the
identifier options
for four different profiles
based on the number,
the identifiers that are
available for each format.
So the monograph profile
has the fewest and the music
and sound recording
profiles have many more.
So the advantage of this is
that if you're only cataloging
monographs you don't have
to sift through a lot of fields
that don't apply to your format.
But if you are cataloging
in a specific format you have
the fields that you need.
And one thing that we
just started a couple
of weeks ago is put in the
perform music ontology terms
for medium of performance.
As prat of the LD for P
[phonetic] linked data project
that Stanford was coordinating
through a Mellon grant,
there was a group of music
catalogers that worked
on a specialized
vocabulary for music.
And their terms for medium
of performance are
much more detailed
than what was developed here
for medium of performance.
So we've been working with how
to incorporate their vocabulary
and their prefix
in the ontology.
And so this is the output where
you can see that BF is used
as the prefix for the
BIBFRAME terms but PML
for performed music ontology
is used for their terms.
Their ontology for music in this
area is very, very detailed.
I think we've kind of gotten
it to work and I'm eager
to hear what the music
catalogers have for feedback
after they've experimented
with it a bit more.
So when you're using the
BIBFRAME there are a lot
of different ways that you
can catalog the material
that you have.
So the first one would be
that you have a brand-new work
and a brand-new instance
and so you start
with creating the work.
This is how a lot
of the cartographic catalogers
are doing their mapwork.
So you can go to the editor
workspace, select cartographic
and choose to start
with the work profile.
And here's an example of all
of the work level
information being added in.
During the pilot the map
catalogers have been really
outstanding to work with
because they really looked
through what the first
profile was that we gave them
and suggested a lot of things
that would make it
better for them.
And then here's their instance
level information it's a bit
more detailed, there's
more fields.
And finally, there's
two local fields.
Admin metadata is sort of all
of the data only a
cataloger could love.
A lot of it comes from
the leader and the 042
and 040 of the MARC record.
And it's stored in
a separate block.
And then there's the
item record block
which we have not really
done a lot of work with yet,
it's fairly generic and not
really Voyager specific at all.
And I think as we go
forward we're going to have
to make some decisions about how
to treat the items in BIBFRAME
because if we want this
to truly be a replacement
for the Voyager ILS are
we going to have to put
in Voyager specific fields
or should be looking towards the
next gen ILS and what it needs.
And these are all
decisions to come.
And after you input all of this
information then you can preview
it to see how it looks in
different RDF serializations.
I believe during the
first pilot this was
like the last proofreading
check before you were done
with the record.
Now it's just a cute way
to [inaudible] the date
in a different way.
And then you click on
the post button and back
in the editor workspace you
have this highlighted area
where it says that the
description has been submitted
for posting into the database
that Nate was just
talking about.
And you can click on that
LCCN and ta-da there it is
in the BIBFRAME database.
This we got working earlier this
year and it's been really fun
to watch the records
go in and out.
And then there's also sort
of this moment of panic
when you hit the post
button and you're
like please work, please work.
Another workflow is to add a new
instance to an existing work.
This happens a lot with
DVDs of television shows.
So we had the Blu-ray
DVD profile
and you select the
instance first.
And then you can either search
in the BIBFRAME database
to find the work that you
need or you can search
within the BIBFRAME editor
but you really only get
the name of the work.
If you want to be really, really
sure you want to search first,
searching in the database
because then you have access
to the full suite
of data to verify.
And then after you link
to the existing work you don't
really need to add anything else
to the work so then you put in
all of your instance level data.
The DVD profile is one of the
longest ones that we've created
and we've tried to add as
much standard dropdown lists
as possible so that the
cataloger doesn't have
to keep typing in the same
bits of data over and over.
And now Les is going to
talk about IBC records
because this is one of our
big recent accomplishments.
>> Les Hawkins: Hello,
I'm Les Hawkins,
I work in the cooperative and
instructional programs division.
And I am excited about
demonstrating this
but it's not one of
my accomplishments,
it's really our colleagues
in net dev who've done this
with the searching and the
interfaces for uploading IBCs.
The other thing about being
able to work with IBCs is
that catalogers in the
BIBFRAME 2.0 pilot told us
that this is very
important to be able to do
because IBC work is very,
there's a lot of different types
of records that are coded IBC.
There's a lot of different
workflows associated with it
and it's a huge part of
LC's cataloging workflow.
So I'm very excited that this,
this is still in development
from what I understand.
I've mentioned a few of the
categories of IBC records
that catalogers need
to work with.
Vendor records, E-CIP record,
ISSN prepublication records,
and I say and others but that
leaves out copy cataloging,
a huge part of the workflow.
Nate mentioned cloning
IBC records
to like build another edition
for an existing record.
So there's just a lot of work
that, this is a large workflow
for LC and I'm very happy
that this is being developed.
I have an example here and
I want to say that I began,
I just found this in the Voyager
database and I applied it
to the BIBFRAME database.
But I started out with a search
in the BIBFRAME database,
I pulled up the record.
And I'm showing here that we
have a link that we can paste
in to the upload into the
editor, the BIBFRAME editor.
So that's what I've done
here, I've copied the link,
the instance link here.
A new feature this last week
was added by our colleagues
in net dev and that is the
ability to choose a profile,
choose the appropriate profile.
Before this feature
was added they just,
all of these IBCs just loaded
into the monographic profile.
And now if you have,
this is an example
of a rare book being loaded
into the rare materials profile.
If you have a serial
IBC, a prepublication,
IBC that you're working
with it can be loaded
into the serial profile.
The thing about IBCs
is if they're
in the database they often
need additional work later.
So that's really
what, I forgot to say
that at the beginning
that's really one
of the important things that
you need to be able to do
with IBC records is
update them later.
And so that that is possible
now within the BIBFRAME editor.
And so this just shows you
pasting in that instance URI
that you copied from
the BIBFRAME database
and submit the URL and URI.
And it brings up the
BIBFRAME instance.
In this case, this is from
the rare materials profile
because I notice that it
has collective title there,
the other profiles
don't have that.
It also mentions here the
RBMS terms that are part
of that particular profile.
So you can make updates
to this record
and send this description back
into the BIBFRAME database.
This is just showing
some of the changes
that you might want to make.
I didn't make any changes
to this to this description
but maybe you want to update the
extent or add an extent or make
in the instance profile.
So over here on the
left I'm making a change
to the instance profile
by changing the extent
and over there on the right
I'm looking at the work profile
to add illustrative
content to the description.
And then it's posted back
into the BIBFRAME editor.
And that's the basic
steps for the IBC.
Do you want to open this
up for questions now
for all of the speakers?
>> Beacher Wiggins: So we're
open for questions, comments.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Nate Trail: Well Stanford
and Harvard [inaudible]
for people [inaudible].
We're going to be
downloading our stuff
and figuring out
what [inaudible].
They're the major
players in this.
There's a bunch of Europeans
that are very interested too,
Scandinavian National
Library is [inaudible],
but they're not actually
using our records [inaudible].
But everyone was very
excited to [inaudible].
>> Have we got any feedback on
anyone using the [inaudible]?
>> Nate Trail: There's one guy
who found some errors in it so.
>> That means they're looking.
>> Nate Trail: You know
that they're looking.
>> Jodi Williamschen: And the
editor profiles are available
for download in GitHub
and I know
that Stanford has
downloaded them.
And made some modifications
so that the lookups will work
because everything on the
editor profiles is very tied
to the LC ecosystem which means
it doesn't really play outside
the network.
And so I'm pretty sure Stanford
has tried to modify the profiles
to work on their system.
Regina.
[ Inaudible ]
There are a lot of things
about the new RDA toolkit
that worry me, that's
just one of them.
And I think it's
something we're really going
to have to figure out.
I'm going to, there's a
program at ALA on Monday morning
about the toolkit that I'm going
to go to, to get enlightened.
I'm also worried about
the loss of rule numbers
since we have a lot of
hot linking in the editor
that is tied to the
URL for the rule.
>> Beacher Wiggins:
[Inaudible] thing is
that we will have a full year
from the time [inaudible]
toolkit
and its content are stable
which will be no sooner
[inaudible] input in December
of this year, so we have a year.
And I've made it clear to our
policy specialists that we want
to determine how we want
to move forward with it.
And whatever linkages we can
make with BIBFRAME [inaudible].
So there will be a
lot, I won't say a lot,
but there will be much
behind the scenes work
to solicit [inaudible] to
make sure we roll this piece
out as appropriately and
as seamlessly [inaudible].
>> Nate Trail: But the impact is
not as large as you might think
because it's more
of a profile issue.
The basic underpinnings
of the editor will work the same
it will just allow the cataloger
to produce more individual works
and then it can be
tied together.
So the configuration step
as we call it [inaudible].
But basically what Jodi
and Les [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
Well I think it's as good
as your MARC cataloging was
because the history of all
the title changes has got
to be recorded in the
original MARC [inaudible].
So when you look at Voyager
records you can see previous,
next, you know, merged
into and all that.
So it'll be just new
ways of expressing that
information and us being able
to write a query that says go
get me that history and show it
to me in the new presentation.
Just like the name title
for [inaudible] browse
that I showed we could do
something like that for titles.
>> And removing the unnecessary
information the display
so you really could configure
I just want title, the dates,
the publisher [inaudible].
>> Nate Trail: Yeah,
but the thing
that we're doing is handcrafted
so we could do a
presentation like that easily.
But when you're talking about a
next generation catalog they're
not going to do [inaudible]
unless that's the new,
you know, the only new way
of doing serials or something.
So that might be needed
to put into requirements
and you'd be able to see that
because we're not building the
library's next catalog we're
building a demonstration
that says here how you
could take advantage of RDI.
>> I think I already
talked down in one
of the next gen meetings
about that.
>> Jodi Williamschen: There.
>> I'm wondering are there
any plans to move BIBFRAME
from browser into
[inaudible] application?
And along with that thinking
of advantages that, you know,
the big one would be may not
requiring a constant internet
connection but also you know
build [inaudible] new key
commands and kind
of like navigate
around more quickly that way.
>> Nate Trail: Well the basic
premise of linked data is
that you're connected to
everything [inaudible].
And so internet connectivity
is kind of built in.
But as far as like
hotkeys for stuff,
anyone can do that right now.
You can do that even
your browser
to tell your browser this
is what I'm going to do,
it doesn't have to be a
standalone application.
>> Jodi Williamschen: Way in the
back was next, then Jessalyn.
>> As a working cataloger
I noticed
that a snappy response
time is one of the keys
to getting records
in the system.
MARC [inaudible] deficiency
for very few characters
to transmit your individual
[inaudible] record.
This system is going to
take more processing time.
I have due concerns
about [inaudible] and the
priority as we upgrade
our systems in general
that BIBFRAME the
catalog has to be fast.
And two, with the changes
in net neutrality
internet service is spotty
and I'm in the [inaudible].
Is there any way we can assure
that our internet
doesn't get dialed back
so that we still
work [inaudible]
government employees?
>> Beacher Wiggins:
That's a big question.
>> Jodi Williamschen: Yes.
>> Beacher Wiggins: That's
a question [inaudible] all
of us frankly.
>> Jodi Williamschen: Yeah.
>> Beacher Wiggins:
These things are brought
up at various meetings
but I don't think we can
answer that question.
>> Nate Trail: And I think
any, if you're a cataloger
in the current environment
slowness is kind of built
in because we're building
ourselves all the pieces
that are necessary to
make something work.
We're not trying to make
a fast machine right now.
So we're in the stage of can
it be done not how do we make
it seamless.
So your slowness will be solved
with a vendor supply RDF editor,
etcetera system otherwise
they won't be able to sell it.
>> Beacher Wiggins: And some
swap-outs that are going on now
with the desktops and plug-ins
will bring some relief.
And certainly our colleagues
in OCIO [inaudible] are.
If not worried very [inaudible].
>> Jodi Williamschen:
So Jessalyn I saw you.
[ Inaudible ]
I can answer the
second question.
It would be great to
have an OCLC gateway
that dropped data right
into the BIBFRAME database
but there's a lot of
technological hurdles
between that happening
now and in the future.
The main one is that BIBFRAME
editor and the database are
on test servers internally and
are not open to the outside.
And to link up to OCLC
there'd have to be a lot
of port traffic opened up.
And I don't think we're
ready to go there yet.
But we understand
it's very important
because downloading records
from any utility is vital
for copy cataloging.
I think if we move more into
a production environment
that would be one of the
top things to get resolved.
And I'm hoping Les can
answer the first one.
>> Les Hawkins: Well no,
but I mean thin this is,
in one way this is how we're
able to do some copy cataloging.
We still have to download
the records from OCLC.
If you work with serials
you have to do your updating
and your work in OCLC, then
you're bringing that record
into Voyager if it's held by
LC or if it's an ISSN record,
a prepublication record.
Those ISSN prepublication
records are IBC records,
they're coded as such
in the Voyager database.
So yes, I have an example
of a prepublication record
that can be loaded with that
process that I just showed you.
So it could be updated
in the BIBFRAME editor
by loading that IBC record.
Other types of copy
that could be loaded
through the load IBC record
I believe if there are IBCs
in the Voyager database
that you've downloaded
from OCLC they can be
uploaded and worked
on in the BIBFRAME database.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
If they are, if you
have coded a record IBC
in the Voyager database yes
you can use that mechanism
that we just showed you.
>> Jodi Williamschen:
Actually you can load
in any record that you want.
>> Les Hawkins: I was going to
say I thought that happened.
So when, you know, we're talking
about serials and there are lots
of post-publication serials that
we work with, we work with them
in OCLC and we download them
into the Voyager database.
But I hadn't experimented
with that.
But I'm pretty sure with the
upload IBC you can upload any
of those records that you've
downloaded from OCLC and work
with them in the
BIBFRAME editor.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Nate Trail: Now I think you
go into the different database,
if the record was in
OCLC and got into the ILS
and then the next day it was
converted into a different.
You can call it up in BIBFRAME
as though it was an IBC.
Use whatever profile now
that you think is appropriate
and it will populate in the
editor, change what you need
to do and save it back
as though it was an IBC.
You don't have to change the
906 or whatever code in order
to make it work you
just call [inaudible].
>> Les Hawkins: And so all
of those records are being,
on a daily basis
all those records
that you've downloaded whether
you've not worked on them
or not they're being converted
to BIBFRAME, they're available
in the BIBFRAME database.
[ Inaudible ]
This is a new feature, this is
why we're excited about this.
>> Jodi Williamschen: If
you can find the record
in the BIBFRAME database
you can recall it
in the BIBFRAME editor
if it's an instance.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Les Hawkins: Got one
question in the back.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jodi Williamschen: Yeah,
I think a lot of the issues
with the connecting up to OCLC
is on the technology side,
getting the machines
to talk to each other.
[ Inaudible ]
I know what I want to do
we just have to figure
out if it's going to work.
Because part of the thing
is that it's two bytes
in the 008 field, and
it's kind of connected
to one BIBFRAME property.
And are we losing anything
else that's expressed
in that regulatory byte to
just have it say irregular.
But we'll get there because
it's an RDA registry [inaudible]
so we should be following
that model as well.
Jessalyn.
[ Inaudible ]
Since the editor is browser
based it's pretty accepting
of Unicode.
The challenge has been
character set mapping,
so if you have a
Chinese keyboard
or not our Hebrew cataloger
in the pilot has
noted some oddities
in searching depending
on the diacritic.
So there's a few things
that need to be ironed out
but it's more on a
data input end I think.
The storage and everything
getting put back
into the database
everything looks fantastic.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, since you are the
Hebrew cataloger Rojay
[assumed spelling].
[ Inaudible ]
That's great.
>> Les Hawkins: Well it's
11 o'clock right now,
how do you all wrap this up?
>> Jodi Williamschen:
We need to go to 11:30
if people still have questions.
>> Les Hawkins: It's
11:30, oh I'm so sorry.
>> Beacher Wiggins:
Are you trying to.
>> Les Hawkins: And this
is being filmed, isn't it?
>> Jodi Williamschen:
Everybody wants to go, you know,
Les wants to go to the parade.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Les Hawkins: I
think there was
at last another question,
sorry was there?
>> Beacher Wiggins: Other,
did we see another hand?
If not, then for those who
are interested in [inaudible]
to the capitol parade you'll
still have time to do that.
Thank you all for showing up.
>> Jodi Williamschen: Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit at loc.gov.